right now with conventions back in vegas
a whole new way to get around the boring
company's new loop
under the convention center is shuttling
passengers underground
but what happens if something goes wrong
our i-team looked into that to get you
some answers david charn is live at one
of the new stations he joins us live
with more
brian we're one at we're at one of three
stations here
outside the convention center right now
these teslas are moving customers
through this system there are two
tunnels underground here
they look like this they're about this
wide so you can see how a car can move
through
but we wanted to know what would happen
if something goes wrong
they're mile long tunnels 40 feet below
the las vegas convention center
moving customers and electric vehicles
under the 200 acre campus
but with new tech comes new challenges
the only thing is we can't drive the
engine right up to the call
clark county deputy fire chief warren
whitney says his department worked hand
in hand with the boring company
charting this new territory aimed at
transporting
8 800 customers an hour the safety plans
for the new tunnels obtained by the
i-team
outline procedures for an underground
crash fire
or other emergency if something goes
wrong drivers are trained to continue on
to the next station
if there's a blockage they're trained to
drive out in reverse
firefighters can enter using carts not
trucks to get to a scene
and if there's a fire a powerful
ventilation system
can push the smoke out giving
firefighters a safe way in
whatever heat and smoke and gases that
are released
will be pulled away and then we enter
from the other side
we think this is just going to be an
incredible amenity and offering to have
for our customers to have a fun way to
move around our campus lori nelson craft
with the lvcva
says it's an exciting time for
conventions and las vegas
she adds while the lbcva funded the
project it's
boring company drivers who are doing the
work below
it was really imperative to us that the
boring company was
equally as committed to the safety and
we're very pleased with the outcome of
the safety and operations
after dozens of drills and months of
practice
the time to get moving is now i'm very
confident in the safety
for not only the passengers but the
system itself
and there are plans to now extend these
tunnels from here at the convention
center
all the way up and down the las vegas
strip brian denise
david that is some cool stuff what about
the safety of the cars themselves
remember we're talking tesla's the
boring company owned by elon musk tesla
of course owned by elon musk and in the
documents that we found about safety
and emergency procedures it actually
talks about the batteries in the teslas
and how they're mounted on the floor
how tesla is one of the safest vehicles
when it comes to crashes
and how the batteries are rarely
involved in fires
brian denise all good news right there
we're getting into jetson's mode now
it's finally starting to happen it's
already here